night king 96  the almighty bortnick  and now you're going for the mad lan  opening  but uh very accelerated version yeah no  it's a  slow version  of the mad land because it goes yeah h4  in the first place that is true yeah  need to focus  he's not played this  very well i would say  51. i don't think there's anything  dangerous  isn't for him either  okay c4 wasn't necessary  it's tense  c7  this just didn't work  oh come on okay i still have some tricks  oh i thought he would go bishop b6  but yes one second left one second i  should be able to do this you should  now i'm probably winning on position  oh i almost blender there  oh  okay let's take the rook yeah  you did it oh my god you did it he  fortunately was very slow yeah  i just can't play a single days in game